well I was biessing since I was a little
kid when I was a very little kid I did a
lot of biessing at home and it got me
through a lot of stuff till I got caught
and I'd had to up my game to be a big
BSA which has followed me around for a
long time
but in all fairness I never thought of
myself as a storyteller I thought of
myself as an individual was striking and
struggling along trying to get make my
way in the world and it wasn't really
until by accident from graduate school
that I went to Columbia Pictures and I
didn't know anything about the movies
and suddenly I was in the center of the
movie universe in the late 60s and they
were making movies and everybody was
talking about movies so suddenly I was a
storyteller want to be and I spent the
next many decades changing will want to
be to going to be to be I consider
myself a teller of purposeful stories
it's a technique it's a talent it's a
craft that I used to shape my life and
my destiny in order to win
when you determine that you're going to
tell a purposeful story there are three
components there's the tail which is
about 75% of the whole thing that's
purposeful that means you have a goal a
reason a purpose for telling the story
you want somebody to do something feel
something think something act or
whatever and then there's the story
which is the narrative that is the
Trojan horse that you embed the
information data and facts that is proof
a process of what you want them to do
inside of the whole concept is is
designed to get people to work together
it's a social cohesion concept it's to
get you to work with me to get something
done potentially for us or for you or
for me so the idea is it's a tool of
life it happens to be the business is a
life science it's about getting people
to enter face themselves
entrepreneurially or executive lea there
is a conceit that somehow story telling
or telling purposeful story is alien to
my experience and I'm not part it's not
part of me it's something that's gonna
be bolted on to me that's not the truth
everybody is a teller of stories
everybody if our species wasn't a teller
of stories we would have gone extinct
because that's the method for the first
hundred thousand years we're on the
planet that held us together to bound us
together the way we created our ability
to have social cohesion long before
Facebook long before Twitter and
LinkedIn in myspace that was social
networks they were called tribes they
work together they told stories around
the campfire they didn't have digital
laws and ones they just said whose in US
and they use them to pass along the
rules beliefs of the tribe to be able to
use the tactics and strategies so they
could outrun a lion a fighter an Austin
I'll beat an elephant otherwise they'd
have been eaten and that's the way it
works those narratives were our
evolutionary advantage and it turned us
from the bottom of the food chain to the
top of the food chain from prey to
predator so it is part of our
evolutionary tools and our evolutionary
advantage and it's inside all of us
we're designed that way
you